hey everybody in this video I'm showing
how I make my custom roofs and custom
walls though the general idea behind
this is how to make any kind of custom
scenery item for your building and place
that around within the building as if it
were just an in-game scenery item so
starting off with the walls as an
example I just want to quickly place an
anchor point for my building place a war
as a reference material for one very
important reason whenever you're making
custom walls our custom roofs or
anything that you want to be able to
copy around and use the grid it's
actually seamlessly make it larger or
smaller you want to make sure that it
actually fits on the grid and the only
way to tell exactly when it fits on the
grid is to use a kind of reference
material to know what the size of the
grid is in this case it's a wall so I
just want to place a very quick wall on
the ground here and I want to make a
very simple stucco wall I just want to
take this texture here put it over the
reference and just copy the size and
shape of that thing
and over here rotate it just get a
slightly different texture make sure
that it connects seamlessly and that
should be it now we can just remove the
wall and place this around and that's
basically how you can get a custom wall
now obviously you can get all sorts of
combinations with this the basic premise
is choose to get a wall reference in and
place any kind of texture over it you
can very easily also just take a wooden
texture say for instance this chief
believe sign I think it's a quite a nice
sign and actually want to use it for
this building here you can just place it
right in there
sink it a little bit it doesn't have
that very nice straight quality on the
size rotate it just to make sure that it
fills the shape in there you can remove
the reference again and then it should
seamlessly connect and you can make
walls out of it a few things I want to
say about this for one don't be afraid
of using any kind of object for this you
can think just about every single object
into a wall to make a custom texture be
it's the back of this air-conditioning
unit or the wood from the pirate rigging
it really doesn't matter as long as it's
a flat texture and it works for whatever
kind of wall you want to make
as long as you get it in on that
reference you can just copy around and
basically use anything now I think you
should also always remove the wall that
you used as a reference not just because
it's a bit of a waste of space because
it will end up a little bit to the lag
in your park for an object that you
don't even see which is quite annoying
but also because it might give you some
z-fighting if you are placing text is
very closely over balls they will have a
conflict and if you zoom out you might
start to see them flickering so I always
like to just remove the walls behind
them sometimes I forget but most of the
times basically you want to get that
stuff out so that's four walls but for
roofs it's slightly more complicated and
the reason for that is that a roof
should rarely if ever be perfectly on
grid you always want a roof to be
slightly off the grid kind of overhang
over the walls that you're placing
underneath it and that seems like it
doesn't really work because you do want
to be able to make a small roof and copy
that around on the grid to make any kind
of shape or size of roof that you want
with a very small piece that you created
for the texture but it might actually
work and I'm gonna show you how I do
that with a few objects first one that I
want to start off with is the sandstone
supports for the brick roofs which
doesn't really make too much sense but
it can look pretty good in some contexts
now what's very interesting about this
sandstone support is that it's about a
quarter tile wide so no matter how you
place it you can always copy it around
and it'll always stay on the grid and
connect seamlessly to the ones that
already next to it only if you have the
quality of grid actually enabled which
at the time we can only just place a
sandstone column and there we go that's
a quality grid so what I do with the
sandstone thingy is to place it right
down the middle of a roof piece like
that the Sun is being really annoying
but you can still tell what the exact
middle is with the lines on the side
here just kind of sink it in - it
doesn't really matter too much and
basically just make that down all the
way I want to make a one tile wide roof
here
but like all roofs do and do it kind of
wants to stick out a little bit on the
bottom so I'm gonna add one more piece
around here that should finish it and as
soon as you've done that you can copy
this round and because it's exactly
centered you can also rotate it and
it'll just connect to the roof that
you've already made and that's how I
usually make these brick roofs now if
you're kind of stupid like me and you
want to make a red shingle or a tiled
roof here's what you want to do though I
have to warn you beforehand don't do
this too much or don't do it at all
because you will end up with many wasted
places that you don't actually see and
it will add quite a lot of lag to your
Park anyway if you do want to do it
here's how to you basically want to take
a door piece which is this one right
here which has that red texture on the
bottom of it and that's what we're gonna
want to use and to actually make good
use of it we're gonna spin it around and
sink it slightly into the roof like that
so that this piece is the only thing we
see and this is why it wastes a lot of
faces as you can see and it's not very
efficient because you don't even see the
rest of the door but it's still gonna
get rendered by the game and it's still
gonna give you quite a bit of lag also
you're gonna want to place two roofs in
this case just because this thing is
gonna be pretty wide and quite annoying
to make so back to the door the first
thing that you want to do is just fill
up the entire thing with door pieces
make sure that there's not one very
small spot of blue left and this is
gonna take quite a while to place as
well but just place them like this
whoops connecting them as closely as you
can because you don't want to have too
many of these doors around until you're
all the way at the end now obviously
there is a big giant door connected to
this roof piece so what I actually like
to do is spin it around here and there
because we're gonna have to spin it
round for this corner to make sure that
we don't have a door sticking out here
and place that in there but I also like
to do is in the middle where you can
just get a few ones with like a slightly
different texture just to make sure that
it doesn't look that repetitive now
because we're lazy you're gonna want to
just at this
throw in here and after that copy the
entire thing make sure that you don't
copy their roofs by pressing on the more
hole in control and place it over there
and that's basically the entire
reference tile filled with roofs but it
does look very boring and it looks very
very straight and terrible actually so
they get like a bit more of a natural
shingle type texture to it it never
really ends up being that great but at
least it looks better than the mess that
it is at the moment I always like
sinking a few of these into it but a
little bit higher just to give it some
slightly different textures just kind of
plop them wherever you want to just kind
of random but give it more of a shingle
texture and make sure that the entire
thing doesn't really look as on the grid
so yeah there is no real technique or
anything to this just adding lots of
random beams here in there so now we've
arrived at something which with a lot of
imagination kind of looks like something
that resembles a shingle roof at least
as close as we can get at this point
probably and all you really have to do
at this point is copy it around I added
the quick horizontal trim at the bottom
just to add a bit of a trim to the roof
and also cover up the roof that was the
reference within it and yeah you can
basically make any kind of size or shape
of roof that you want to with this one
thing that I would recommend though is
especially if you get into larger roofs
or you repeat them quite a bit just
randomly remove a few of those beams
that you put in there just to make it
all seem a little bit less strict and a
little bit more random so that you
actually do have less of a pattern in
these shingles on top of it now if the
question is does it really look great
I'll have to disagree with that as well
it just doesn't really look that good
but in the context of whatever kind of
theme you're going for it can actually
work pretty well even if the texture
isn't really that perfect for it if you
do you have the right text if you do
have like the right sort of general
feeling or a texture to it and the right
color which in this case is quite
important since it's really just about
the only way to get a Red Roof Inn
it can at least be somewhat acceptable I
suppose for alpha 3 until we actually
get some different moves this is just
about what we're gonna have to do with
this also keep in mind we might be able
to do all sorts of stuff with this kind
of method in later alphas with more
objects but this is basically how it's
done kind of reference make sure that
it's on the grid and build whatever kind
of textures you want to on it but please
watch out with those unnecessary faces
they can really add up to a lot of lag
in your parks anyway that's it for this
video thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys next time